I'm Michelle Guthrie I'm at providence
equity investing in Hong Kong I'm very
interested in this in this Devils
question about whether geopolitical
issues will outweigh the economic crisis
in the East Asia and I don't agree with
that I think that that ultimately what
you know matters to most people in East
Asia is is there security in terms of
employment opportunities in terms of
growth for them for their economy and I
think that they I'm probably
overwhelmingly optimistic that the
geopolitical conflicts will will be
sorted out because of the you know into
inter mingling of countries and and the
ultimately the the fact that everyone
wants security so I'm convinced that
that as a as a practical matter even
though we'll have bumps along the way
that frankly everybody is going to do
the right thing and you know that that
the geopolitical conflicts will be
sorted out and I think them the most
pressing need in East Asia is really
setting the the path for for future of
continued growth and integration of
vegetation to the global climate thank
you